When you start out in business, it's
unbelievably hard.
And the reason that business owners at
the highest levels get compensated the
way they do is because they were able to
make it through that period. They earn
the right to earn more in a day than
people earn in their lifetimes. You have
to learn how to behave in hard
circumstances so that you can continue
to make it through the hardships that
will inevitably
come as you grow.
And
growth comes from a deficiency between
your current and desired or your current
and required. You need to be here and
you're here and that stretch hurts
because you're inadequate. You have to
look at yourself in the mirror and be
like, I'm not good enough.
And they call them growing pains for a
reason. And so, if you're like, man, I
wish I could grow really fast, you're
actually wishing for a tremendous amount
of pain for an extended period of time.
And then when people don't have that,
they hit their first pain, they're
somehow surprised that it hurts. And the
thing of the pain of business is it's
not just like this visceral physical
pain. Of course, you have those from
time to time. But a lot of the pain of
being in business is not knowing the
[__] you're doing and feeling like an
idiot. Being like, why am I not good
enough? Why do these other people Why
are they doing so much better than me?
Like, what conclusions can I drive
derive from that? There's only one of
two paths. Either I have something
outside of my my control that I can cast
my blame to or I have to take the punch
to my ego and say, I'm just not that
good. That guy is better cuz he's
unethical. Okay, sure. If that's what
makes you feel better, and now what?
And so, the things that make it hard is
that one, you have to accept that you're
not good and you have to do it over and
over and over again. Right when you
think you're good again, the world
proves to you that you're not as good as
you think you are.
And this happens at all levels of
business. The same thing is when you
have those plateaus, it's been a year,
it's been two years, it's been three
years, right? It means that you haven't
changed. You've behaved the same and so
you're getting the same outputs. And the
change is painful. And sometimes the
painful change means that you actually
have to take two steps back and your ego
not only has to get hurt, but hurt even
more.
Because you have to realize that you
built your thing wrong. You hired the
wrong leader. You have the wrong team
culture within a department. What do you
do? Well, you either leave it there and
stay stay perpetually under your
potential because you weren't willing to
confront the difficulty of the
inconveniences that are going to come to
you as a result of making the change
that you know you need to make but
aren't making.
And so, I bring this up because we feel
like we're the only people who
experience this. Like, our pain is more
than other people's. Our love is deeper
than other people's.
But when we do that, we rob ourselves of
the ability to learn from others that
came before us.
The other people who already learned
what this is like, who've described the
pain. And listen, even if you try to
take as much advice as you possibly can,
you're still going to get burned. It's
still going to hurt.
I have yet to see
someone
really start figuring out what's going
on in less than 5 years. And I'm saying
5 years of being in the game. Not 5
years of I have an idea, I'm really
passionate about this. I've been reading
stuff on the side. I work on the
weekends. I'm saying all in for 5 years.
And you just start. You just begin to
get a grasp of what it takes to to be
good at business.
And the difficulty is that
it's so hard to teach business in school
because it changes so much. The
principles remain the same, but the game
changes.
And I think that we judge ourselves
because we somehow believe that we're
behind other people. It's one of the
most painful things that we can do is
that we just obviously you compare
yourself and then after making the
comparison, there's nothing wrong with
comparing yourself to other people.
That's how you figure out discrepancies.
But then you label. Then you say, and I
suck as a result. And I'm worthless. And
I'm not never going to be good enough.
Right? But it's the first part is
valuable. That guy is better at ads than
me. What is he doing that I'm not doing?
I should learn that, right? Not that guy
is better than me at ads and therefore I
suck as a human being and will never
win. But if we zoom all the way out and
really think about this cuz this is a
little bit trippy. The game of business
has been going on since the dawn of
time. There were merchants in ancient
Egypt 5,000 years ago that were in the
game of business.
And the game of business will never end.
It's an infinite game.
Who was the number one merchant in Egypt
5,000 years ago? No idea.
Who was the number one merchant 4,000?
2,000? 1,000 years ago? 200 years ago?
No one knows.
And so, we have this idea that we're
somehow going to become number one. But
I'm like, at what?
At net worth? And then eventually your
kids become trust fund kids?
And then that gets divided up 10 more
ways cuz no one's got game like you? And
eventually you just you've got, you
know, eight family members on the Forbes
list? Okay. And none of them are the
ones that actually made it. None of them
know how to multiply cuz they aren't in
the game. They never learned the skills
of the game?
Like, if you see the game as constant,
the only thing that changes the players.
So, my mom used to say this thing which
was
um and this is I doubt this is her
quote, but the news is always the same,
only the names change. So, think about
that. So, you look at the headlines,
right? It's like,
bankers get greedy. Sound like new news?
No, they just changed the names. You
know, jealous husband kills wife then
self. Same news.
It's not even news. It's just humans
being human.
And so, business news is also the same
way.
Hot new technology comes out. Grows
really fast. Find out actually not good.
Crashes quickly.
Investors lose millions.
This stuff is the same. Boy learns how
to sell. Boy learns how to advertise.
Boy learns how to make product. Boy
eventually makes lots of money. Boy
eventually gets old, tries to, you know,
give back to a certain degree, becomes a
philanthropist. Old in his age, retreats
a little bit. The next of kin comes in
line, not as good as that person,
maintains, third generation destroys.
It's just humans doing human [__]
Right? And so, I say this because a lot
of the hardship of business is comparing
yourself and labeling that comparison
and saying that I'm not better or worse
than these people, but all the players
on the board are going to get swapped in
100 years. All the players. The whole
board gets wiped.
The game still goes on, but the players
change.
If you can actually give yourself
a pat on the back as long as you do one
thing, which is that you stay in the
game.
You keep playing. You keep rolling the
dice.
You have my offers book? No. Let's see
if I can grab it. Hold on. Oh, my leg I
did legs this morning. Hold on. Oh, you
know what? I think it's my I think it's
the leads book. So,
this is the story of the many-sided die.
So, I wrote this. I didn't hear this.
This was just like a concept I wanted to
uh to share.
So, imagine you and a friend play a dice
rolling game.
You're each given one die.
One of the die has 20 sides. The other
has 200. On each die, only one side is
green and the rest are red.
The point of the game is simple.
Roll green as many times as you can. The
rules of the game are as follows.
You can't see how many sides you have.
You can only see if you roll red or
green.
If you roll green, one of your red sides
turns green and you get to roll again.
If you roll red, nothing happens and you
get to roll again.
The game ends when you stop rolling and
if you stop rolling, you lose. So, what
do you do?
You roll.
When you roll red, you pick up the die
and roll again.
When others roll green, you pick up your
die and roll again. When you roll green,
you pick up the die and roll again. You
keep telling yourself one thing. The
more I roll, the more greens I get. At
first,
you roll green once in a while.
But as more red sides turn green, the
green happens more.
With enough rolls, hitting green becomes
the rule rather than the exception. So,
what does your friend do?
He rolls a few times and hits red each
time.
He sees you roll a green and complains
that you must have a die with fewer
sides. He reasons it's the only way you
could have rolled green before him.
And although you did, you also rolled
many more times. So, which is it?
In either case, he rolls a few more
times in frustration and hits a green.
But then he complains about how long it
took. He spent more time watching you
and complaining than actually playing.
Meanwhile, you've hit your green streak.
It's so much easier for you, he tells
himself. You get greens every time. This
game is rigged. So, what's the point?
And he quits.
So, who got the die with the 20 sides?
Who got the die with the 200 sides?
If you get the game, then you see that
once you roll enough times, the die
you're given doesn't matter.
The die with fewer sides might roll
green sooner.
The die with more sides might roll green
later.
But a die with a green side always has a
chance of rolling green if you roll it.
Every die hits its green streak when
rolled enough times.
All of us get a many-sided die.
And looking at the other players, you
have no idea if it's their hundredth
roll or their hundred thousandth.
You don't know how good other players
are when you start. You can only see how
well they do now.
But if you understand the game, you also
know it doesn't matter.
A few begin playing early. Others begin
much later. The rest sit on the
sidelines complaining about how lucky
the players are.
I guess so.
But they're luckier because they play.
And when they hit red, which they do,
they didn't quit. They rolled again.
Learning how to advertise is a lot like
the game of the many-sided die.
You don't know
if it's going to work until you try.
And
no matter how many players there are or
the number of sides in the die you're
given,
you start to see the only two guarantees
that the games will give.
Number one,
the more times you roll, the better you
get. Number two, if you quit, you lose.
So, I read that story because that's
obviously a story of an infinite game.
You and your buddy
get given two die. One of you has a
20-sided, the other has a 200-sided die.
You don't know who has which.
And there's one green on each. You roll
it, and if if you hit the red,
uh nothing happens. If you hit a green,
you get one of your many sides that
turns green, and you get to roll again.
And the only statistical probability
there is that if you keep rolling enough
times, all of the sides will turn green
on both die eventually. But you just
don't know how many sides the die that
you're given has on it that are red.
Which means you just don't know how many
shots you're going to have to take in
order to win. And that's why having high
frustration tolerance,
having high fortitude,
having high resiliency, and high
adaptability, those skills of mental
toughness are what allow you to stay in
the game of business. It's what allows
you to keep rolling the dice even when
you get smacked at 20 times in a row as
reds. Because maybe you have a
2,000-sided die. But if you know that
the one fact of this game is that if you
keep rolling, you keep playing, and if
you keep playing, it means you're in the
game. And if you're in the game, it
means you've won. Because in infinite
games, there are no winners and losers.
There are only players and quitters. And
so, when you are starting out, you were
just early. You have more reds left to
roll. You just got to get them out of
the way. You got to get the failures
out. It's the only way you figure out
how to play.
You just don't want to lose so bad that
you die. But as long as you don't die,
you can keep playing.
And I feel like that actually is a
pretty hopeful message. Despite my
relatively aggressive demeanor.